>>> NEW TONIGHT, THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYS IT WILL TRANSPORT ITS FIRST
BATCH OF BABY FORMULA FROM
ERSEAS THIS WEEKEND, WHICH
COMES AMID GROWING OUTRAGE
BECAUSE ITS SHORTAGE IS
STRETCHING INTO ITS THIRD MONTH.
PARENTS ARE DESPERATE WITH
SCENES LIKE THIS PLAYING OUT IN
STORES.
>> LOOK AT THIS.
LOOK AT ALL THIS.
LOOK AT THE SHELVES.
YOU DON'T THINK I NEED IT FOR MY
BABY TOO?
>> THIS IS THE WHOLE REASON WHY
THERE'S A FORMULA SHORTAGE.
YOU TAKE ALL THE FORMULA OFF THE
SHELF AND BUY ALL THIS AT ONCE?
>> YOU GET THIS ONE.
>> THIS IS THE WHOLE REASON WHY
THERE'S A FORMULA SHORTAGE.
YOU COME AND YOU BUY ALL THE
FORMULA AT ONCE AND THERE'S KIDS
WHO NEED FORMULA TODAY WHO WON'T
BE ABLE TO GET IT BECAUSE YOU
JUST BOUGHT IT TO STOCK UP.
>> OUTFRONT NOW, THE MOTHER WHO
RECORDED THAT VIDEO WHO'S BEEN
STRUGGLING TO FIND FORMULA FOR
HER 3-MONTH-OLD BABY, COLTON,
WHO WE'RE SHOWING THERE, AUTUMN.
I KNOW YOU'RE MAKING A POINT
WITH THE VIDEO AND OBVIOUSLY YOU
DIDN'T FILM THE OTHER MOTHER'S
FACE.
YOU WERE JUST TRYING TO SHOW THE
INCIDENT AND NOT CASTIGATE THE
PERSON INDIVIDUALLY.
BUT TELL ME WHAT LED UP TO THIS
VIDEO AND WHAT YOU SAW WHEN YOU
GOT TO THE BABY FORMULA AISLE.
>> SO ORIGINALLY WHEN I GOT TO
THE BABY FORMULA AISLE, I
EXPECTED TO SEE WHAT I HAVE SEEN
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF MAY,
WHICH IS -- I KNOW THE FORMULA
SHORTAGE HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
WHILE MORE THAN THAT, BUT WITH
COLTON'S FORMULA SPECIFICALLY,
IT'S JUST BEEN OUT SINCE AROUND
THE BEGINNING OF MAY.
SO I'VE BEEN GOING TO TARGET
ALMOST EVERY DAY OUT OF THE WEEK
FOR THE PAST ABOUT THREE WEEKS
NOW AND CHECKING FOR FORMULA,
CHECKING FOR THE NEXT BEST THING
TO HIS FORMULA.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WAS DOING THAT
DAY.
I WENT THERE.
I SAW THAT THEY HAD IN STOCK THE
CLOSEST THING TO HIS FORMULA.
HE IS ON A SPECIAL FORMULA,
WHICH HE DOESN'T TAKE WELL TO
ANY OTHER FORMULA, NOT EVEN THE
ONE HE'S ON RIGHT NOW.
BUT WHEN I GOT THERE, I STOOD
BEHIND THE LADY FROM THE MOMENT
SHE HAD AN EMPTY SHOPPING CART.
SHE TURNED AROUND, WE MADE EYE
CONTACT.
I GAVE HER A SMILE.
I LET HER KNOW WITH BODY
LANGUAGE THAT I WAS WAITING
PATIENTLY.
I WASN'T SAYING ANYTHING,
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
SHE WAS ALSO ON THE PHONE.
SHE WAS ON FACETIME.
AND I PROCEEDED TO WAIT AND SHE
LOOKED BACK AT ME A FEW MORE
TIMES.
SHE STARTED TO WALK AWAY WITH
THE CART.
I SAID, EXCUSE ME.
AND I PROCEEDED TO ASK HER FOR
ONE CAN OF FORMULA.
>> SO AS YOU'RE STANDING THERE
CLEARLY WAITING, SHE JUST TAKES
EVERY CAN OFF THE SHELVES?
>> YES.
AND CLEAR AS DAY, THERE WAS NO
OTHER FORMULA AROUND HER LIKE ON
THE SHELVES, TOP OR BOTTOM, THAT
I COULD HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR.
BUT YES, CLEAR AS DAY SHE JUST
CLEARED THE ENTIRE SHELF INTO
HER CART.
>> SO WHEN YOU ASKED FOR THE
BOTTLE JUST FOR ONE BOTTLE, WHAT
DID SHE SAY?
>> SHE SAID NO, THIS IS FOR MY
BABY.
I NEED TO FEED MY BABY.
THAT'S WHEN I STARTED TO RECORD,
WHICH LUCKILY I HAD MY CAMERA
OUT ALL RIGHT BECAUSE I WAS
READY TO TAKE PICTURE OF THE
FORMULA AISLES.
AND SO I JUST SWIPED OVER AND
STARTED RECORDING SO I COULD
KIND OF -- I WANTED OTHER PEOPLE
TO SEE WHAT IT'S LIKE TO FEEL
FIND OF HOPELESS AS A MOTHER
WHEN YOU GO TO THE STORE WITH
HIGH HOPES AND KNOWING, OKAY,
THEY HAVE THIS ONE THING THAT I
CAN GET, I CAN AT LEAST FEED BY
BABY WITH THIS, AND LEAVE WITH
NOTHING.
>> YOU SPENT EVERY DAY GOING TO
TARGET AND DOING THIS AND JUST
THE EXHAUSTION AND THE STRESS.
HOW DID THIS SITUATION RESOLVE
ITSELF?
>> IT REALLY -- IT HAS NOT.
I HAVE YET TO FIND FORMULA.
I HAVEN'T GOT MY HANDS ON ANY OF
IT WHATSOEVER.
I'VE PUT PLEAS OUT ON FACEBOOK
TO TRY TO FIND SOME.
RIGHT NOW I'M SUPPLEMENTING WITH
THE ONLY FORMULA THAT THEY HAD
LEFT IN THE STORE THAT DAY,
WHICH WAS SIMILAC ADVANCED.
IT'S NOTHING CLOSE TO WHAT HE
NEEDS.
SO IT'S VERY ROUGH NIGHTS AND
ROUGH DAYS OVER HERE WITH THE
BABY.
HE'S NOT TAKING WELL TO IT, BUT
I'VE CALLED HIS PEDIATRICIAN,
THERE'S NOTHING ANYBODY CAN DO.
>> AUTUMN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SHARING THIS STORY.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO YOU.
I KNOW THAT'S STRESS WITH HIM
TAKING IT.
I'M SO GLAD YOU FILMED THAT AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU DIDN'T SHOW HER
FACE, BUT I HOPE PEOPLE --
ANYONE OUT THERE WHO CAN
UNDERSTAND WHO WAS IN THE OTHER
SEAT, NOT YOURS THERE, WIL